a theme music please the first question
that I'm just gonna answer because I
feel like everybody in the world has
asked me this if I am the gta5 girl no
I'm not her and let me tell you who also
is not her it's not Kate Upton and it's
not any of the people that anybody ever
expects it to be she'll be well under
Shelby Shelby is in fact the model that
they based this girl off of the funny
thing is it actually doesn't even look
anything like her I do now have the
black iPhone and that was my excuse that
everyone's like is that you I said no no
I have a white iPhone but now I don't
so moving on to actual questions Steve
Bartlett is asking if I've ever seen
something that have a hard time
explaining and to be completely honest
with you I have a hard time explaining
myself to other people they're like what
do you do I say I make videos on the
internet they instantly think they
instantly think the worst it's like no I
didn't like friendly as like puppies and
kitties and talk about video games and
what does a fox say I love that video
Jessica was to know what I do if Apple
went out of business I really have no
idea I've never actually thought about
that because it's kind of rare that
there's been these big companies that
kind of just random like a lot of
business although I do remember flute
video when they kind of mmm I think
we've all quickly moved on except for
shaycarl the only person in this
planet's to logging not only every
single day with vlogging every single
day with a flip video so props you Jay
Kyle ones need to subscribe my first
kiss I wish I could lie to you and say
that it was amazing but I don't even
remember it it must have been extremely
unmemorable I think I remember who it
was though think this is gonna question
this is an order from Alexander wants me
to get to wanted level 5 and GTA and you
know what buddy I am going to take on
your challenge so stay tuned to my
gaming channel because it's gonna happen
I don't want to know if I could be
invisible for a day what would I do I
would probably go around in department
stores and put on clothes on my
invisible body and just walk around
because people would just be freaked out
to see clothing just walking around I
might also rob a bank but I would take
the money that I robbed and glue it to
my invisible body and also walk around
the next thing I would do is I would
actually take all of my clothes off of
my invisible body and just walk around
naked I will go to the store naked but
nobody would know that I was naked but I
would know that I was naked does this
make sense to you guys
ok Selena wants to know where I got my
Italian Greyhound and how much it was um
well I don't have one so if I were to
have one I would probably know how much
it was so in return I can't actually
answer any of your questions here sorry
if I could be a kitchen appliance what
would you be
obviously I'd be a blender my obsession
with my blender is it goes real deep I I
love this thing I'll put anything in I
will cook anything in it if you haven't
realized that by now what I live in a
video game GTA saints before probably
not unless I had
unlimited lives because if you guys have
seen any of my videos you know that I
die quite often that's probably not in
my best interests also the things that
happen in these games I would never want
to be in a world where these things
could actually happen so let's just get
down to it no I don't want to be in
either one of those games I got to know
I feel well the Breaking Bad finale it
was perfect
there was a point about halfway through
that I was getting a little nervous as
they were gonna let me down and I was
going to be very upset I don't let me
down but pretty much the entire world
down this isn't watching this series
they pretty much tied up every loose end
that they possibly could honestly I
don't think I could have asked for a
better ending so that's yeah I'm happy I
like it I've watched it four times so I
thought it was great I think it have any
exotic animal which would it be probably
have a tire so I could go around singing
I'll the tag of my excited for fall
winter I live in Los Angeles so
basically fall and winter and summer and
spring are all the same there's really
no seasons here it's all just kind of
one big really nice day that just never
ends I am looking forward to going back
home and visiting my family because I
bought some Camel uggs I feel like every
one of you guys had sent me these and I
finally was like I need them I need them
in my life
so they are on their way to my house
right now I can't wait for some cold
weather so that I can put them on my
feet there you go feet people mmm
present for you
oh my thoughts at iOS 7 do I like the
flight designer wear like the previous
design I'm actually a huge fan of the
new design it definitely took some
getting used to my only complaint is the
transitions when I open something I want
you like a little transition animation I
want it to pop up and be on my screen I
click open
stop let's just stop so that being said
I do actually like it I'm kind of used
to it and I think yeah hopefully in some
future updates
it'll speed up these animations a little
thank you guys for watching this episode
of ask IJ did you check the last video I
posted subscribe do whatever you want to
do really I don't like being told what
to do so I don't want to tell you what
to do we're done here bye